killers of the flower moon is a deeply
personal tragic story that holds major
Family Ties to many of its cast members
at its core it's a heartbreaking story
of indigenous people told through a lens
of impressive improvisation personal
ties with the oage nation and painful
unresolved family tragedies that still
haunts one of the actors to this day
although the screenplay for this movie
was strategically and carefully crafted
there was still a little room for improv
this was also an aspect that Cara Jade
Meers who plays Anna Kyle Brown really
loved in regarding her performance
though the scene itself is rather
heartbreaking it was the scene where she
and her sisters Molly Minnie and Rita
were at a picnic talking about the white
men and how although they were obviously
shady and trying to steal their money
they couldn't help but find them
attractive that whole scene was
improvised she said even though the
scene itself is happy if you know the
ending it's much more Sinister these
women were genuinely trusting and loving
and they expected their husbands to take
care of them and protect them I briefly
mentioned earlier that this movie has
many personal ties to the cast one in
particular being yansy redcorn who plays
principal Chief Bonnie Castle he pulled
from his experiences observing his late
Father Charles redcorn and his uncle
negotiate with members of Congress on
behalf of the Osage Nation something
very Bittersweet about this movie for
him was that it opened with a scene from
his father's book a pipe for February he
said that his father was never an
outwardly emotional man but he knows
that he would have been floored over
that yansy redcorn couldn't help but get
swept up into the stories of all the
real life people involved in this
tragedy let's talk about redcorn's
great-grandfather yansy redcorn's deeply
personal connection to killers of the
flower Moon doesn't stop with his late
father but goes all the way back to his
great-grandfather Raymond redcorn senior
who was poisoned and his case to this
day remains unsolved the whole system at
the time was heinously corrupt and it
made it pretty much impossible to find
out who was behind it everyone from the
neighbors local pastors morticians
doctors police and the government are
all included in that statement so it's
like who was there to go to the case
still haunts redcorn's family to this
day if it weren't for narratives and
projects like this the majority of
people would have no idea about these
tragedies that have so deeply affected
people's lives for Generations they're
hoping by bringing these stories to life
that it can help others cope with the
loss of their loved ones the red carpet
seems like it can definitely be an
anxiety inducing experience especially
being an indigenous actor telling a
story that a lot of people in power
don't want to be shared all three
indigenous actors were completely
overwhelmed in the most positive way to
be surrounded by their indigenous peers
while walking the red carpet they're
hoping this film can encourage
conversation about Native history and
the major issue of the many indigenous
people who have gone missing Without a
Trace or Inquisition unfortunately
stories like this are extremely
difficult to get out there especially in
places like Oklahoma where they have a
ban on critical race Theory Cara Jade
Meers is deeply motivated to get this
story out to the public people didn't
care about natives back then like the
line in the movie you're more likely to
go to jail for kicking a dog if you know
the rest of that line you'll know how
gut-wrenching it is for these actors to
talk about so Leonardo DiCaprio I'm sure
you've heard of him told the costume
designer of the film Jacqueline West
that he thinks they worked on a
masterpiece that's not something he
usually says considering he's been
working in Hollywood since his childhood
so that statement isn't to be taken LLY
Leonardo has been talking up this film
since 2019 describing it as one Epic
Master Orchestra led by Scorsese he's
been heavily invested with no signs of
letting up on getting this story told he
co-produced the film and took on the
role of Ernest Burkhart whose loyalties
are conflicted with his family and his
personal ambition I'm not shocked by
this at all but due to the deeply
emotional story backed by such an
impressive cast critics are saying that
killers of the flower moon is going to
be a major player come aus season due to
the fact that these characters are based
on real people throughout history it
gives the film that deep rooted personal
Edge that audiences can't help but be
drawn into it's expected to be nominated
for Best Picture best director for
scorey best adapted screenplay for
scorey and Eric Roth best actor for
DiCaprio best supporting actor for dairo
and best supporting actress for
Gladstone this will be Leo's sixth Oscar
bid that will put him at the same level
as two Cinema icons Richard Burton and
Daniel de Lewis it's also pretty crazy
to think about how this could have been
a completely different story I'm not
going to leave you hanging there let's
talk about it Leonardo DiCaprio was
originally cast as Tom white a Texas
Ranger turned FBI agent that got sent to
Oklahoma after receiving a harrowing
phone call from the O Nation the
original script had all the makings of a
classic Western or murder mystery they
didn't want it to be told as some white
savior movie considering who the actual
bad guys were so instead they decided to
focus on the relationship between Bill
and Earnest Robert dairo explains the
thought process behind that decision in
an interview with deadline they wanted
to focus more on that Dynamic instead of
Tom white coming in and saving the day
that shift created the much more
personal story that we have today the
decision to cast Robert dairo as
Leonardo DiCaprio's uncle was one of the
best things that could have been done
for this movie as it ends up playing
into their real life father-son
relationship Dynamic that has developed
between them over time Leonardo says his
career was launched by doing this Bo
life where he first met and auditioned
with Robert dairo working with him
watching his professionalism and the way
he created his character was one of the
most influential experiences of my life
and career coincidentally Leo also ended
up doing a ton of films with Martin
Scorsese but they didn't end up coming
full circle until 30 years later where
they all ended up working on this
project together Robert dairo is
apparently a man of few words but
according to Martin Scorsese he was
impressed with Leo from from the very
beginning he said I'm working with this
young boy you must work with him
sometime that was the first time I heard
him recommend somebody to me the kid is
really good all three of them ending up
on this project together was a surreal
experience for Leo to say the least
something else Martin Scorsese has to
say about Leo is that throughout all the
years he's worked with him the reason
why he's always so impressed is that the
guy can just go there he goes to these
really weird places that are so
difficult and convoluted and through the
convolution somehow there's a Clarity
that we reach he says there's just
something about the subtle movements of
his face and the way his eyes look that
really bring the scene to life it's
almost unexplainable apparently there's
something in his face that the camera
looks into in his eyes the slightest
Movement we know it he said he could
just film Leo basically just chilling
out not thinking about anything in
particular and it could be taken to a
context completely out of this world the
guy just goes the extra mile in every
aspect I mean do I have to bring up the
Revenant right now or no you get it
let's talk about his character Ernest
that was honestly barely in the book at
all there was a lot of back and forth
between Leo and Martin Landing on the
role of Ernest it was a bit of shock to
Martin when the topic came up because
there really wasn't a lot written about
him narratively Martin reflects on the
conversation with Leo that brought the
character to life he is the weakling a
man who was in love with his wife but
he's poisoning her he was like yeah okay
how are we going to do that Leo really
wanted to go into Uncharted Territory
with the film's characters so they did
it's almost unclear whether nnest is
ignorant or in denial of what he was
doing to his wife but every scene was
carefully constructed even some up until
the day of the shoot it was hours days
rather of work they pretty much lived on
set day and night even through the
weekends it's no shock though as the
film runs at about 3 and 1/2 hours
originally when Leo ended up changing
his role Paramount stepped out as the
principal financier and with a runtime
as long as this movie it created a lot
of pressure for Martin there was a lot
of talk about the runtime and it was too
much for the theater but it ended up
being unavoidable due to the nature of
the film the risk is there showing in a
theater in the first place but the risk
for this subject matter and then for
running time it's a commitment Martin
says that spending 4 hours in the
theater for this film will without a
doubt enrich the audience's life
spending the evening or the afternoon
with this picture with this story with
these people with this world that
reflects on the world we are in today
more so than we might realize he
believes that it is a concentrated
effort for audiences to nurture an
appreciation for films like these
especially ones that are meant to be
seen in the theater but it's films and
risks like these that make this career
worth it for everyone involved the cast
of killers of the flower Moon didn't
hold anything back everyone on this film
worked tirelessly night and day to tell
the complex gut-wrenching story of a
nation of indigenous people whose voices
didn't get to see the light of day this
film full of deep emotion rooted in
historical trauma could only be told by
an ensemble of people willing to take a
risk how many Oscar nominations do you
[Music]
predict